اليوم فقره السفر منا وفينا وعلى برنامج
على فين السياحي الذي يعرض على منصه اكثر
العلامه الرقميه التابعه لشبكه العربيه
بالتاكيد البرنامج طبعا مشاهدينا حصل
مؤخرا على جائزه تحكيم القريه العالميه
لافضل تقرير تلفزيوني عن تغطيته لفعاليات
موسم القريه 27 زميلتنا احلام اليعقوب
مقدمه البرنامج اعلنت عن الاستعداد لاطلاق
الموسم الثاني من على فينو الذي يحلق هذه
المره الى دول شرق اسيا الموسم الاول
مشاهدينا ركز
على منصه من السعوديه والبحرين
ومن خلال هذه الرحلات اصبح لدى البرنامج
متابعات عاليه تخطط الخمسين مليون مشاهده
منذ اطلاقه
[موسيقى]
الاستديو راح تنضم لنا زميله مدري اقول
الزميله ما ادري اقول الصحفيه مدري اقول
الصديقه احلام اليعقوب صبحك الله بالخير
جهزت الشنطه
دائما اناقتها ودائما تتالق بهذول يعني
القطع المميزه اللي دائما من وحي رحلاتك
هذا من وين هذا من هذا يعني
بدايه مقدمه
ان شاء الله بدايه خير رايحين نقتحم شرق
اسيا نستكشف ونغوص في هذا الجمال الساحر
اللي كنا نستلد فيه وبجمال عن بعد الان
راح نكون ان شاء الله عنقها طب احلام انا
اعلم يعني شخصيه احلام على المستوى الشخصي
لكن اليوم برنامج على فين قاعد يطلع بعض
من الجنون الصحفي لاحلى من جاز التعبير
اليوم ايضا انت رايحه الى شرق اسيا الوقت
صيف احلام تحب تجرب وتاكل راح تاكلين تريد
فود ليش ما ناكل وين رايحه رايحين اول شيء
الهند بعدين
خلص هذه يعني تفتح لي كل الوقت
الاندونيسي كمان رايحين اندونيسيا ان شاء
الله بس بالبدايه حنمشي بالخريطه
على فين الاقرب الى الجزيره العربيه هي
الهند يعني الرحلات ما تاخذ ثلاث ساعات
فحابين نبتدي الرحله من هناك نستكشف
الالوان والنكهات والثقافه والرقص الهندي
وبكل تفاصيل هذا الشعب الجميل بعدين راح
ننزل على السريلانكا من سريلانكا مكملين
الى تايلاند منها الى اندونيسيا ايضا
الخطه تشمل ان شاء الله كمبوديال الفلبين
الاوس فيتنام كل هذا المنطقه اللي احنا
تحديدا ليه ما رحتي غرب لان الناس
متوجهه الى الغرب بشكل جدا كبير وفي ماده
ثريه بهذا الجانب ولكن الان مع التقارب
الجميل اللي كان سابقا من خط الحرير وما
زال هذا التقارب الرائع والجميل ما بيننا
وما بين شرق اسيا جميل ان نستعيد
ذكرياتنا
وبثقافتنا جزء كبير من ثقافتهم وصلت لنا
عبر السفن وعبر التجاره فاتوقع من باب رد
الوفاء والجميل الان ان نعطيهم من
اهتمامنا بشكل اكبر التاريخي والثقافي
يعني لاختيارك حتى للوجهات واختيارك لما
ستشاهدين وما تريديه ان تشاهدي في كل بلد
يعني حتى كنت مثل ما في تقارب ثقافي تكون
في تقارب بيننا كيلوين بخور كمبودي على
كيفك هذه الصلاه
ربما التصوير وما سيراه المشاهد هذا متعب
لا التحضير ياخذ وقت جدا كبير ولكن صراحه
وللحقيقه احنا خلاص ان شاء الله السفر يوم
الاحد فانا جيتكم بملابس الشنطه جاهزه
للحقيقه هذه نقطه جدا مهمه انت ذكرتها
الان المحتوى محتوى السفر والسياحه ليس
حديث
والزوايا كثيره وفي وثائقيات وفي شغف جدا
كبير والتلفزيونات كانت تتسابق والصحفيين
من داخل غرف الاخبار برضو كانت هذه ضمن
مهامي السابقه ولكن صراحه مدير المعلومات
التنفيذي في قناه العربيه الاستاذ فهد
الصغيبي لما اطلق منصه اكثر كان يجمع بين
حاجتين وهذا ذكاء لمواكبه العصر ان يجمع
بين الصحافه الاستقصائيه الثقافه الحقيقيه
اللي تشوفو بمفهومها ليس فقط التقليدي
وانما الغناء الصحفي لانه هذا نادر وما
بين وسائل التقنيه الذكيه والمتطوره علشان
تقدر انت تطلع بماده واكب فيها المشاهد
وتلبي احتياجاته واضح ونجحتوا بشكل الحمد
لله على فين يعني بقدر انه يحقق اكثر من
خمسين مليون مشاهده يعني وهذا هذا باقل
تقدير على بعض من المنصات فما بالك ايضا
على شاهد مبالك عندما يعاد تدوير هذه
المواد بطريقه او باخرى فهذا هو المطلب
الرئيسي انك انت توصلي برضه معلومه فليس
كل من يقتحم عالم التقنيه او التلفاز هو
صانع للمحتوى من
الزاويه والنظره
انا ناطر البخور شكرا جزيلا احنا
منتظرينكم وعادل حتى انت عندك شغف جدا
كبير يعني انا ما انسى رحلتك البريه هذا
ترى مغامر جبار
يوصل اخر مكان في العالم شكرا جزيلا احلام
الياقوب على فين احنا بانتظارك شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات